yo boo lay cap show we got a special
guest in here shout out to the homie
black boy jb welcome man i appreciate
you for having me bro congrats on the
new album uh i think it's dope that you
and t keith kind of collaborated on on
the album because i feel like um
we don't be seeing that a lot you know
like nas and hit boy have been doing it
uh
but like back in the day i feel like
there was more like
you know a whole was it fully produced i
know he executive producer but he do all
the beats as well he did out of beats
yeah i think that's dope like um
obviously you guys are kind of
synonymous when we think of blackboard
jb i think of tay keith that's when i
first heard him you know what i'm saying
so whose idea was it to like do a collab
collaborative project yeah take it
he called me one day was just like bro
i ain't gonna lie i think it's it's time
for us to do the project cause we been
post it was already overdue so he just
hit me with like yes it's i think it's
time for us to just do that
i'm like okay well sister you want me to
be on the old block i'm gonna go and
write the whole thing and
that's how i did it that's how it is
right um
how dope is it to kind of just see like
uh
his you know
like how he's leveled up in in the game
as far as a producer because like
from the days of like your early stuff
where we kind of first heard of take
keith and heard his tag
um
now he's like you know one of the
biggest producers in hip-hop like it's
crazy like you know all the records he's
done like and that's your boy too so
yeah that's got to be dope to see yeah
i'm proud of him every time i see him
because it's like we spoke all this [ __ ]
to his inst like
we spoke to existence he said he said i
always you always say man i'm gonna make
it to the top and making beats at first
we both used to [ __ ] around rapping we
both are rapping with me he's just like
my i'm done rapping i'm scraped beats
that's what's going to get me out he
knew exactly what he was going to do
that's dope i just saw uh gotti did he
just gift you this chain yes i saw that
was it yesterday yeah that's a big deal
man
so that's a serious uh
i mean you are you have some serious
jewelry but that's got to be i mean the
cmg chain that's kind of official yeah
it mean a lot to me yeah was that your
first like uh i mean obviously you have
chains with your own stuff on it right
but like was this your first like like
you know in hip-hop
when you get that label chain it's a big
deal it's your first time having
something like that yeah if so that's
dope man i feel like when you first came
on the scene
i was a little confused about your
situation
because you were like you had the drake
record and that [ __ ] came out through
warner brothers and then you had a
project come out on empire
and i was very just like this guy's
signed to like seven different people
it's official you're s
it's cmg
interscope correct yeah so
how's um
everything been man like just in general
we've been good it's been chilling
i i was telling uh you you would we you
know we had a freestyle and you text me
um
and uh you know we swapped information
and when you called me
it said biggest [ __ ] is
[Laughter]
calling i was like i don't know how you
got your phone to do that
but that's for people who don't know i
didn't have your number saved
so if you call someone who doesn't have
your number saved that pops up biggest
[ __ ] is calling
if so has that ever been like a uh
an interesting situation transpire when
when when someone you don't know misses
your call no to be honest i i just did
it probably like three weeks ago so
everybody i've been kind of black
who the [ __ ] is the biggest [ __ ] like
who the [ __ ] is the bigger [ __ ] and i'm
like
yeah you know it's me michelle
how is the [ __ ] culture different in
memphis you think
than it is over here because we're in la
you know this is the birthplace of this
[ __ ] oh see like the other thing that's
really different is it's a lot of
politics out here in memphis
it's like you got
great streets you got bounty hunters
riding with grave streets in memphis
it's like but i heard they rivals
they don't vote with each other at all
but this this [ __ ] is like that would
never happen out here yeah no out here
that's but in memphis you got [ __ ] it
ain't about to click cause you got
[ __ ] there's there's gravestreet
bounty hunter but they they could since
they blood cousins so they gonna ride
with they blood for anything before the
yeah
out here it's this is not the case
because it's just too deep it's too deep
um so yeah cause it's crazy because like
you know we had dusty locain uh come by
and he's a rolling 60 right and like uh
allegedly he raps about it um
and just like you're allegedly yeah uh
but
i'm like yo that's crazy that it's like
your your role like rolling 60 in this
neighborhood like he barely he never
even visited you know like he when he
came out to l.a for the first time he
finally had like went and tapped in with
like big you and those guys but like
it's just got to be like it's kind of
crazy like there's grape street in
bounty hunters in memphis
yes it's everything memphis
indeed what do you think like you know
how's the temperature in memphis right
now man it feels like a very divided
place depending on what part of town
you're in like
yeah it's it's really clicked up grouped
up it's all type but it ain't it ain't
no it ain't no no gang
it's it's more squatted it's like more
clicks and everything
is it uh are you still are you still in
memphis no
smart if so for sure smart um
but like just in general like do you
feel like um
do you feel like it's starting to calm
down a bit in memphis you know obviously
there's been a lot of i mean we lost off
and it just feels like a lot of shitty
going down in memphis you know what i'm
saying like all the time do you do you
feel like that that's just like that's
just your city and it is what it is or
it ain't gonna never come down to the
city gonna do what they do
so that's all i gotta say about that
that's fair
and the grizzlies are going up yeah for
show the greater going up but this city
is it's crazy
it's just
you just gotta know how to move out
there
do you feel like um because i think i i
always say this memphis you know we
think of like
errors in hip-hop when new york had it
when la had it
atlanta's had it for like [ __ ] 20
years now right but i feel like low-key
like you guys kind of got it right now
like if you think about
money back yo yourself and elite chop i
mean we could go on and on and on and on
with all the artists out of memphis
do you feel like right now it's like
memphis's time in hip-hop
yeah for sure
it always has it always have been it's
just
it always just like
there was like people certain people
that that was coming up in memphis they
always just run into a lot of
violence [ __ ] get locked up [ __ ]
killed [ __ ] right type of [ __ ] just
happened
yeah i mean i think even like back in
the day like i feel like 3-6 mafi didn't
get a lot of the credit they deserved
back in the day
because like little john and the
eastside boys kind of just took what
they did and just did it in atlanta and
it
like
you know 3-6 was like kind of they burst
so much like the crunk [ __ ] the chanting
and all that [ __ ]
yeah
when you were coming up were you [ __ ]
with hypnotized mines just like on some
like fan [ __ ] or was it like a little
before when i was growing up i i only
heard them on the radio i i just i i
couldn't buy i ain't got no cd player or
nothing like that so i only played what
was on the radio so i used to listen to
a lot of eminem and ti and [ __ ] like
that
that's crazy eminem
yeah for sure
did you like uh end up buying any m m
albums or you just heard what was on the
radio
like did you go tap in like dive into
eminem's catalog i watched some of his
videos on yahoo you know they used to
watch you know yeah who used to have
videos back then yeah
shout out to yahoo [ __ ]
they that didn't last long i mean it
lasted long enough they got pace a lot
of people
there youtube and google just [ __ ] the
whole [ __ ] up nobody's when's the last
time you used yahoo as a search engine
have you ever like gone to yahoo.com and
tried to find something i tried to log
in my old yahoo i couldn't find my
password the yahoo emails yeah you know
it's crazy when someone sends you an
email and it says yahoo i judge them
they're like yeah shoot me an email it's
blah blah yah come on like bro you
haven't gotten a gmail yet like what are
we doing like you said it's your old
email obviously you you're not using
that actively no
when's the last time you tried to log
into your myspace
i tried to login it i got loud in it i
got old pictures from it that's all i
want to do and get some my opinions yeah
i tried to do that [ __ ] um
i don't know maybe a year ago
and it i just i i don't know if i just
forgot my password i could not get in
because you can't just go to like your
old profile and like because it's all
[ __ ] up now i think you gotta log in
to get your old pictures
do you remember uh
what was your top song on your myspace
profile
um
forever
drake yeah that was a good one yeah yeah
they don't deserve so
in retrospect a pretty crazy lineup of
rappers on that that record was it
eminem drake
lil wayne
kanye yeah
it's pretty that's when they used to
make them real songs yeah
yeah you don't think people do that
anymore yeah they do but you know know
when people used to read their collab
with anybody just to make music every
night you got certain people to be
pressed out you know what i think
happened is the internet just [ __ ]
everything up like because now
fans speculate so much about people
having issues with each other when
there's really no issues that i think it
sometimes
artists start to believe that [ __ ] they
end up not working with each other
yeah
so i feel like back then
it was just my space
you know like and if it wasn't like
people had twitter or they had
an instagram story there'd just be so
much blog [ __ ] going there was no even
yeah i mean the blog [ __ ] like not right
and two dope boys in those sites but
even then it was like different like
it wasn't nothing messy or nothing it
wasn't messy it was just more you
understand the good with everything good
that they do right because you'd have to
wait for the magazine interview to drop
now someone's got a problem with someone
they just get on ig live and just talk
about killing them like
it's it's too with an instance like you
can do it right now
and i think people make like like people
do that [ __ ]
because it's so quick you might be in an
emotional state you just turn your phone
on and get that [ __ ] out on the internet
and then it's out there forever
have you ever done that were you like
like like was it was feeling the type of
way or you you put that [ __ ] online and
you regretted it later i ain't never
been
just no really really internet type of
person to be honest i don't even
just be on the internet club i got a
problem i'm just gonna
solve it when i see i t everybody around
you that i'm gonna do it on the phone
and everything but i won't probably
shouldn't do that on the phone though no
because guess what if i'm telling a
[ __ ] something like that i'm talking
about beating a [ __ ] ass i ain't
talking about doing nothing right
because it's about my [ __ ] if i'm
talking about my [ __ ] about my [ __ ]
got
hey we gotta stop the podcast man real
quick appreciate y'all for watching uh
really mean mean it subscribe like leave
a comment even if you're one of those
[ __ ] who leaves a comment you're
always interrupting the guest because
it's my [ __ ] podcast i don't know i
like to talk too
anyway
hey shout out to odd socks man they've
been our sponsor from day one we go hard
for odd socks always man
literally go hard for my wife and i go
hard for odd socks
in different and same kinds of ways you
know what i'm saying sometimes i go hard
in odd socks
they do make boxers
you feel me
anyway um listen they got the ill
licenses they got the breaking bad they
got the wwe they got mountain dew they
got [ __ ] swedish fish [ __ ]
kool-aid
uh
pez you know
cheech and chong what are you into the
odd socks basics are the boys though
that's my favorite you know you get
yourself a nice pair of just basics
they're comfy it's like walking on
clouds all right so you can save 20 off
if you go to oddssoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev that's
one word bootleg kev
all together
at checkout 20 off oddssocksofficial.com
go show some love and let's get back to
the interview
uh what's it like you know i think yo
gotti is rivaling
gucci mane as
the best hip-hop a r the last like 20
years because i think gucci's
would you just think of all the people
who he's helped start their career
whether they were signing him or not i
think he's the goat when it comes to
just his ear and the a r ship but god
he's right there
cmg is becoming like a
[ __ ] empire it's really dope to see
what is it like kind of having him
you know as a mentor as somebody who you
could call on you know he's you know i
respect the [ __ ] out of gotti so what's
that like
it's like
basically
it's like everything really because like
if i need advice on anything i know that
he hadn't been through everything like
he didn't have
he had ups and downs with the music so
he know
how to jump jump back so that's what i i
asked him for everything
that's dope yeah he's uh
man like
and you know what's crazy is i remember
i was in the studio with gotti a couple
of years ago and he was like on
soundcloud like trying to find [ __ ] like
new artists and [ __ ]
like he's got his like he's super tapped
in
ear to the street [ __ ]
do you get free tickets to the soccer
team that he owns now
i ain't gonna lie i ain't trying i ain't
trying to get no tickets to the second
game
do you watch soccer
no yeah me either
i watched a couple guys before but i
ain't what i just it's just too long and
it takes too long for you you can watch
the whole game to me it's like hockey on
grass but without fighting yeah i watch
hockey because there's fighting and it's
smaller not because it's fine it's just
like maybe maybe real deal roughing them
up right
maybe ram and [ __ ] [ __ ] they don't
always fight they just be tough as hell
nah but you get slammed into a glass
[ __ ] wall
20 times
nba just imagine nba like that if if the
nba had even something similar
the people who'd be getting contracts
would be so different that bring charles
oakley out of retirement [ __ ] your
boy zebo would have never retired
because he'd still be getting 25 million
a year just to [ __ ] people up into the
[ __ ] wall
yeah they need to put one of them
buttons on 2k
they need to do a uh nfl blitz well they
did they did nba street so i guess they
did do that right well they did nba jam
what are we talking about of course
technically nfl blitz is the nba
is the nfl's version of nba gym
yeah
nfl blitz was fire
and nba street nba street volume one and
two was that [ __ ] though
you used to do those combos were you
[ __ ] handling oh so good i heard that
they're uh doing a new one though
i actually hope so if they do that it's
crazy john moran got to be lit on there
i need to make a new dev jam
def jam vendetta i have it on my phone
uh i got a psp i installed on my phone
the one i showed you
that's the first thing i downloaded was
def jam vendetta i got it on guy
gamecube is a slept on system
we never give gamecube it's flowers
great system are you a big gamer yeah
i'll be playing the game a lot you play
a lot of old [ __ ] like go back and like
tap in i play the old [ __ ] but i don't
play too much new [ __ ] i knew [ __ ] i
played call of duty call of duty yeah
i heard that it's getting like well i
didn't he told me that it's getting like
it's glitchy the new one
oh yeah i ain't never seen the glitch i
guess that's only on rebirth i don't
play rebecca i don't know i don't play
that [ __ ] at all you know when those
games started popping bro i just
realized
i was too late
because i hopped on
and i got killed and then i got killed
and then i got killed again and i just
was like all right well listen i missed
the wave everyone who's playing it
already is way advanced [ __ ] that's how
i started but [ __ ] you gotta learn
you gotta get on your feet and walk and
then i got a little [ __ ] 11 year old
kid calling me a gay slur on a [ __ ]
microphone i'm like what am i doing this
for why am i subjecting myself to
[ __ ]
virtual virtual murder both both vocally
and literally you know do you ever talk
shitty people on the on the game
like you got the headset and [ __ ] no i i
don't i don't get too much time to talk
to them i just be playing i'm talking
[ __ ] to one of my [ __ ] because i i
don't gotta read the two of the [ __ ]
over the guy and they'll be doing dumb
[ __ ] oh
so you've beefed out what did the guy do
in the game that had you like actually
literally mad like for real man
uh
man i told my [ __ ] mt
to get a [ __ ] uh
search box and this [ __ ] winning got a
most wanted
so the most wanted to make you everybody
he's talking about some that he don't
get the money like that i'm like bro you
can go get the search bar you can get
all of us back this [ __ ] wouldn't have
got the most one got killed in 15
seconds bruh
i like bro i ain't gonna lie i'm done
playing with you got the guy
i don't know what any of that means
because i've not played if you knew if
you know you know you don't he knows
that's like that man
damn
uh is what's your is your online handle
like biggest [ __ ] or block like like
blackboard jb or something this is
blackboard jb i ain't got no numbers you
ever have [ __ ] hit you like man
you ain't the real black boy jb you full
of [ __ ]
yeah some folks just be like this i
ain't black boy jb but
it'll be like that often because i don't
play with random i just play with my
folks play with your homies yeah that's
dope do you uh have you have you ever
tried to do the twitch thing
i tried but that man it takes too long
like they want me to do seven day play
the game seven days after week
i can't do that like well record my i
could play it but i can't record just
keep setting up the camera and doing it
for seven days
i heard t grizzly's making some real
[ __ ] money doing that [ __ ]
chief making a lot of money doing it
this month but
you got to do them seven days first i
ain't had time to sit down and do seven
days yet
wait you gotta play seven days
in a row yeah seven days in a row laughs
you gotta play seven days in a row for
like two hours
i mean
knock it out man that's a nice revenue
stream you're gonna play games anyway
give me a chance to get your personality
out there
also gives you a chance to say some
stupid [ __ ] forgetting that you're live
on the internet so you might you know
i couldn't do twitch because i go to you
i'd get canceled if i did twitch because
i would totally forget that i'm [ __ ]
live and there's like people watching
and i would definitely get cancelled i'm
out of here bro yeah i get counsel too
because i got folks that just run around
and just say something just the way i
talk like to my friends it's it's it's
just not
it's very
2004 not very 2022.
they put yeah i'd be a right it'd be a
wrap for me um with this album
do you feel like uh you you feel like
you got like something to prove with
this project
yeah
i got a lot to prove i i just really
well really it ain't even a lot it's
just basically i just feel like a lot of
stuff that goes over here because i rap
too fast so i have to slow it down and i
actually
haven't wrote a song since
rover
so
i i started back writing and getting
back to the old like everything taking
my time your old format yeah so let's be
clear when you say you haven't wrote a
song since rover you mean like writing
it down in your phone or before you
would just freestyle punch in yeah punch
in freestyle yeah do you feel like
writing cause you know nowadays everyone
punches in and i think it's a gift in
the curse with it like you said because
you don't really take your time i feel
like it's lazy i just feel like because
at first i always that's how i came up
i'll be right so i feel like if you came
up off of
writing and you then you go back free
you go to freestyle and you changing on
your whole
like
ground-up game like you came from the
ground up right
you sitting up here doing some stuff
that that ain't help you ain't come on
like this so why are you doing this it's
like a [ __ ] a [ __ ] going
being a comedian then just jump to being
a rapper
it's like you ain't go up doing this you
got to stay doing this because that's
what all your fans want you to do yeah
no that's real so this is kind of like
you're back this whole album you were
writing
it's kind of like you know i guess then
the title of the album says it all right
yeah for sure just back to the [ __ ] that
got you here mm-hmm
do you feel like um
because your [ __ ] like when we think of
like look alive and rover and shoot
these records were pre-tick-tock right
yeah for sure
pre like tick-tock is like
kind of
i mean as big as those songs were the
plaques you got off of them and the
money you made and all that man i'm just
like damn
this this this [ __ ] would have been
crazy on tick tock yeah for sure has
there been any sort of uh effort with
these tick tockers they just resurrected
uh
the jerk [ __ ] what's that should call
the new boys the jerk
that's the thing on tick tock that they
try to like uh
uh
obviously your your signature dance that
we all know about that they done did
they did it a lot i don't seen it a lot
but
it's just i just now i don't know how to
work tick tock like this it's a it's a
lot
it's not like instagram there's a lot of
go bro there's an art to that [ __ ] it's
like editing a [ __ ] music video to
get a good tick tock bro
so you just got on tick-tock yeah i just
got on t-top man you got to go crazy on
tick-tock bro
i feel like your personality
man
that's where it's at i was uh when
someone just told me tic tocs to do
sound cloud that's where everyone's
discovering music now which kind of
sucks
because i'm not on tick tock
i hate that [ __ ] my son and my wife be
on this [ __ ] no stop
um what record if someone were to just
put the album in
well they're not listening to cds
anymore
someone pulls your [ __ ] up on apple
music this new album what's the
what's if they can only choose one song
for someone to listen to what would be
the one song you'd want them to listen
to
uh no chords part 13. that's the intro
right that's the the first from from the
get-go just the first song
if you can't say if you tell me that
this [ __ ] ain't hard you it's just like
how mine you is capping are you a hater
you a hater in a kappa it's like you
can't even say that ain't no
this is the 13th version of the no
chorus you've done yes
i like that like it's like top three of
my no chords so
the thing is
if [ __ ] say that it ain't [ __ ] head
can't not when they playing this song
first off the beat you gonna be nodding
you can't nod to what i'm saying you
just say
was there ever a takeheath beat
that you either recorded on or you
passed up on
right that you heard later that became
like a smash
um
no but then i missed a song that i don't
heard some beats that i don't have
before people and that they don't even
say that they were four like that but so
you had them like in your email and then
oh [ __ ] now it's you know
what give me an example of one
i can't remember because it was like
because they don't happen often it ain't
happened it happened in two years
because i told them i was like oh man
look if you just set my beats aside and
i'm when you send me the beats i'm gonna
heart the one that i'm using and and if
you if i ain't using them just you can
do whatever you want to them yeah like i
need my [ __ ] don't send that don't send
them out to everybody because what if
you write to it and then it you know so
whatever
travis scott
album whatever whatever i wrote to i
hearted it so he knew exactly what i
wrote to so it wouldn't be this is all
in an imessage right
i like that
just heart and everything shout out to
tay keith um
if there was another producer in the
game that you could do album with
besides tay keith who would it be
[Music]
metro
that'd be fire michelle
shout out to metro
uh your city has
you know an amazing uh
just landscape of artists right now and
i mean
always right who would you put in your
top five memphis rappers of all time
and you can't say yourself because that
goes without saying you would be in
there right mm-hmm
scheistie
he's on the album yeah
free shyster
bag
gotti
chopper
three six three six i like that and
ellie chapa always had told me that you
guys have a really like you kind of kind
of helped
30 yeah well that's six then yeah i had
to see yeah um
talk about your relationship with nlp
chopper because i remember
like the first couple times i hung out
with him
he said that like he really like you
guys are were really locked in and like
you kind of
you know
like like back in the day [ __ ]
like when me me and choppa uh we didn't
grow up knowing each other but like me
coming up i used to do these little
instagrams
so i made the instagram live so i used
to go live
and i used to check [ __ ] on
there so i didn't [ __ ] around and
looked at chopper i mean chocolate had a
little roast session me and chop had
roasted and ever since then i just knew
him so every time i went on my life i
added chopper
before he even started rapping so he
sent me some [ __ ] he was like he had a
song and [ __ ]
he sent me the song and then he dropped
the video and went for going crazy like
yeah
he did it yeah he's doing his thing for
sure i don't even think he's 18 yet he
might have just turned 18. yeah 18.
he must have just turned it that's kind
of crazy to think that kid's done all
he's done and he's barely just became
old enough to buy a pornography magazine
ain't that some [ __ ]
yeah be 18 to buy a playboy the [ __ ]
going on out here all right well look
the album is out um appreciate you
pulling up man go are you on xbox or are
you on playstation xbox
well go find him on xbox and uh maybe
he'll let you in on the crew and
you know don't don't go for the most
wanted if what's it called a survivor
box
is that what it's called
no
scavenger
it's kevin
you guys are [ __ ] in
yeah yeah i'm locked in for sure i
played it hey i'm wondering do you have
a relationship with any of the guys on
the grizzlies
what's up y'all got to interrupt the
bootleg cab podcast we have a brand new
sponsor
and i love this sponsor i've been giving
them my money for a long time it's about
time they gave some back my bookie yes
that's right
if you are a gambler if you're not a
gambler let me tell you my bookie is the
best place to go alright super bowl
season is here super bowl 56 is right
here and trust me my boogies double
deposit bonus is something you don't
want to miss if you sign up at my
booking now use the promo code bootleg
that's b-o-o-t-l-e-g
to have your first deposit matched
instantly
up to a thousand dollars so if you put a
thousand in they'll match your thousand
dollars and you get in on all the action
for super bowl 56 i mean seriously
joe burrow versus matthew stafford the
rams are playing the super bowl at home
in la what does that even mean because
none of these home games i've been to
them
it's a lot of out
outdoor fans coming in the 49ers took
that place over twice in the last month
we'll see how the bengals fans show up
all right this is the most important
game of the year it's the biggest game
of the year and you can get paid by
watching it my bookies giving you
everything you need to do it with that
double your money you can double your
winnings and the best starting point for
the big game is these super bowl prop
bets they're fun
anybody can do these right
hey mom what color do you think the
gatorade is going to be to get spilled
at the end of the game hey what about
that toy the coin flip is it heads or is
it tails whatever it is is matthew
stafford going to throw a stupid-ass
interception probably
probably
is joe mixon gonna score a touchdown i
like it i don't know get in on that prop
back action and uh listen even if you
don't pick on who's gonna win you you
could be a winner all right uh it's a
great look the prop bets are the most
fun for the super bowl so don't miss out
head to my bookie double your first
deposit up to a thousand dollars by
using the promo code bootleg
place your bets get ready for the
unmatched excitement for that super bowl
that is a thousand dollars in free money
that they will match so you deposit a
thousand they match a thousand bet
anything anytime anywhere with my bookie
let's get back to the podcast
john moran i mean he'd be the guy right
he's he's that [ __ ] right now
mm-hmm i used to [ __ ] a crowd when he
was in memphis too oh my boy manages
jake crowder now he's on the suns and
that's the best team in the nba crowd
he's there we turned that the games on
my mama yeah jay crowder is a a good
dude and uh you know he's on the best he
upgraded teams
no you know that one it was one game he
was there oh he he told me he was like
when i finally hit this i'm gonna hit
this buzzer beater
and then come down and drop pass on the
ball that boy hit the three
hit it hit it wow
shout out to him he was only on the
grizzlies for a little bit too yeah then
they what they traded him to uh miami
right then he went to phoenix
now he's in phoenix the best team in the
nba
that's a factual statement we have the
best record and it's not close anyway
listen blackboard jb what you're trying
to say about the greed and that
what i'm trying to say is come on man
yeah it ain't gonna
if the grizzlies run into the suns in
the playoffs it's going to be ugly for
y'all it's going to be ugly for y'all we
have the what are we
do you watch do you watch
basketball we ain't even got the team
yet we got injured [ __ ] and
still winning
deandre ayton has played like 18 games
this year and we have the best record in
the league we haven't we don't even have
10 losses yet having a guy in job play
i don't [ __ ] know he missed that he
missed dinner almost 10 for sure
yeah come on man that was going crazy
this is the deal yeah let y'all leave
let david booker go out what y'all gonna
do when
no we beat the warriors when devin
booger was out it happened how many
times i lose against sorry [ __ ]
not many because we're
we uh
listen let's do this
if the grizzlies and the suns play in
the playoffs
we need to do a wager
all right
i'm down you got my number we could do
money we could do
i could send you a devin booger jersey
you gotta wear it post it on social
media if if
if
i got a song i didn't book you have a
song called devon booker wait a minute
wait a minute so how the [ __ ]
wait a minute you have a song called
devin booker and you over here lying to
youtube about the grizzlies being better
than the suns
you're lying to these i said bill you
say what i said devin booker
different booger without them booger so
you love devin booker he got a lot of
fun with him do you have a song called
john marant no of course not because
devin booker's better
[Music]
i don't say well i would say that hey
listen guys one-on-one devin booger
again is that trump by john marie listen
boys let's listen
what a broke ankle i'm not sure that's
po i'm not sure that's true but what i
do know is you're from memphis
you have a song named after
a phoenix sun cause i [ __ ] with devin
booker but you don't [ __ ] with john
marant that much cause you don't got a
john marantz song cause look i said they
devon booked them like the phoenix suns
okay well listen i like the line by the
way was this what year would this song
come out no it just came out oh it just
came out
okay
i got to play that [ __ ] in phoenix like
i was but i was [ __ ] with them i was
[ __ ] with them without going to win
the championship did you send the song
to devin booker
no i'm not yet
you should send it to him
i'm gonna send it to him but he still
can't beat jotto
i mean the sons can beat the grizzlies
though he's i mean i mean for the full
team they probably do if my boy jarrod
jackson beat [ __ ]
jared jackson is is not on the grizzlies
anymore
he gone he's been gone yeah but jared
jackson jr is not gone
what crazy he's a he puts it
he's on the pistons right now bro no no
oh wait wait wait i'm thinking of josh
jackson yeah i'm thinking of josh
jackson jaren jackson by the way you
want to hear something crazy about jared
jackson
he raps yeah i know did you know that
you gotta be hearing them my phone
saying in the studio it's not good
though
he recorded he recorded some music and i
was there and um
i was i just he asked me what i thought
i said hey man listen bro i think you
should focus on um
you should just focus on that basketball
yeah yeah
yeah i did hang a lot [ __ ] tell me
something like that boy i'll be hot i'll
be ready to go this was right before he
got drafted
and i was like
yeah man like you know you should
probably just worry about basketball
[ __ ] like uh this rap [ __ ] ain't for
everybody
i think he does it as a hobby like it's
funny
i totally my brain is broken all it
takes a couple years you can be
perfected you can come out there [ __ ]
sound like wine
yeah but why he's i mean isn't it is he
gonna he's not gonna make any money
damien lillard isn't making any money
off of his music he's not recouping or i
mean maybe he's making a little bit of
money but like he's also making 35
million dollars a year comparing to his
basketball money but it's a cool thing
just know that you got some loot um
i was thinking of josh jackson josh
jackson the sons traded josh jackson to
the grizzlies
and then you guys released him and then
now he's on the pistons jaren jackson
he's a beast
he's the beast he's been out a lot too
[ __ ] with java nobody ain't [ __ ]
with john marin i mean nobody
listen man make a [ __ ] job call me
when you make a john murray song kirby
curry he cool he cool i don't like her
give him buckets but
kevin kevin durant
no we talking about point guards oh
different healthy one guard in my eyes
no he's a shooting guard he's a point
guard he's a shooting guard
by definition
he's a point guard he just played the
two
chris paul's the point guard bro okay
chris powell don't be doing all that he
don't ever pass the ball guess what damn
booker do shoot the ball cause he's a
[ __ ] shooting get the plays he set the
plays and pass it to chris paul so chris
paul can run do it ugly look and throw
it somewhere else that's why he don't
you know you know the point guard never
get to assist like that all the time
listen all the time
he's a shooting guard yeah i know i'm
saying the point guard don't ever get
this inside of time
chris paul does
because he's he leaves he don't play the
point like that he don't play he don't
run the plays who run the plays
girl with the ball chris paul
devin i watch every single suns game man
when i see the guys he watched devin i
have nba league pass the suns games
don't come on tv here so i have to watch
fast too
did you watch your grizzlies yes i
watched the grizzlies
hey look you guys are on fire the new
album is out shout out to shout out to
the album go get that thing um and uh
yeah i look forward i hope you get on
twitch
yeah i hope i hope i do
do the um crazy play the um
song
hold on
they might play on sunday i know for a
fact they gonna trim their ass hold on
about 10 or more
okay
so just so we're clear
the suns beat the grizzlies
by
25 points on november 12th
the suns
beat the grizzlies by 25
points on november 12th so that's
already happened
then you guys beat the suns by one point
by one
who was playing john was gone huh no he
played look he played when they beat
them yes uh by 25 points by 25 points
jamaran played
this is this is the box score to the
game that's who all played [ __ ]
everybody played and y'all lost by 25
points
listen man don't disrespect my sons we
out here that's there's a reason why you
made a devin booker song and it's
because you're really a sons fan the
next time they play is amazing
what the [ __ ] you want to be honest
you're a celtics fan i got a tabby
what you see us [ __ ] yeah i love i'm a
good guy
he's just he's a celtics fan i'm i
digress we're done
boom